[Musik]
Ringlicht an und Action wenn Oma zu
Besuch ist werden tiktoks gemacht Erin
Goodman aus New Jersey ist 17 Jahre alt
seine Großmutter 84 ihre Videos sehen
auf Social Media Millionen Menschen
[Musik]
vor eineinhalb Jahren haben sie ihren
tiktok-kanal gestartet heute zählt ihr
eine halbe Million Follower in kurzen
Videos erzählt Toba Friedman von der
Zeit in Auschwitz und beantwortet Fragen
zum Holocaust
[Musik]
damit wollen die beiden möglichst viele
junge Menschen erreichen
wie viele haben wir jetzt
8,7 Millionen wie ist das wenn man so
beliebt auf tiktok ist
ich betrachte mich nicht als Tower
Friedman er als Vertreterin der Kinder
die nicht mehr hier sind es ist also
nicht meine Geschichte ich habe überlebt
um ihre Geschichte erzählen zu können
es ist die Geschichte von etwa
eineinhalb Millionen Kindern die
ermordet wurden
eineinhalb von insgesamt etwa 6
Millionen Juden die den antisemitischen
Wahnvorstellungen des NS-Regimes zum
Opfer fielen der Völkermord an den Juden
im Zweiten Weltkrieg der Holocaust
Toba friedman ist fünf Jahre alt als sie
nach Auschwitz deportiert wird in das
größte deutsche Konzentrationslager
[Musik]
als wir ankamen nahmen sie uns die
Kleider und ich erinnere mich dass mein
Haar abrasiert wurde niemand hatte mehr
Haare alle möglichen Haarfarben waren
auf dem Boden gestapelt
sechs Monate verbringt sie im
Kinderlager bis Auschwitz befreit wird
dieses Foto geht um die Welt links Tower
Friedman
das ist der Tag der Befreiung der 27
januar 1945 als die Russen kamen
ihre Geschichte hat sie in einem Buch
festgehalten ich war das Mädchen aus
Auschwitz
Jahre später kehrt sie zurück aaron ist
auch dabei er ist damals zehn filmt mit
seiner Kamera
nicht töten konnte ihr seid das beste
Geschenk ihr und meine anderen
Enkelkinder
auch die Aufnahmen von damals
verarbeitet Aaron zu tiktok Videos die
Idee zum Kanal kam ihm als er merkte wie
wenig User auf der Plattform über
jüdisches Leben und in Holocaust wissen
ich dachte das passt tiktok ist nicht
nur Spaß man kann damit auch eine
Botschaft verbreiten Ideen und
unterschiedliche Kulturen das ist vielen
nicht bewusst
Unwissenheit schürt Antisemitismus auf
tiktok sagt eren
ein Rapper der antisemitische Parolen
verbreitet ein Ex-Präsident der sich mit
Holocaustleugnern zum Abendessen trifft
oder erst kürzlich Flugblätter mit
antisemitischen Botschaften in Georgia
in den USA sind judenfeindliche
Einstellungen so verbreitet wie seit
Jahrzehnten nicht mehr das zeigen
Umfragen der NGO Entei der Formation
League
soziale Medien sind ein Beschleuniger
bei der Verbreitung von
Judenfeindlichkeit sagen die Autorinnen
Monika hübscher und Sabine von Mering
die Ausmaße von Antisemitismus auf dem
Plattformen fast gar nicht zu erfassen
die große Schwierigkeit ist dass es in
so vielen verschiedenen Formen und
sprachen vorkommt also es gibt means
Gifs alles was es an Tools gibt um
Inhalte auf Social Media zu generieren
eine Untersuchung der UNESCO zeigt fast
jeder fünfte tiktok Inhalt der sich auf
den Holocaust bezieht leugnet oder
verzerrt ihn
tiktok setzt nach eigenen Angaben
Technologien und moderationsteams ein um
solche Inhalte zu entfernen doch
Antisemitismus kann in kodierten Formen
auftreten in Symbolen Songs emojis oder
filtern
ist das Problem und die codierten Formen
sind eben selbst für Experten nicht
erkennbar und das heißt dass dann also
junge Menschen die irgendwelche
antisemitischen Posts auf ihrem Feed
haben dass die das unwissend das ist
Antisemitismus ist auch weiter
verbreiten
auffällige Inhalte und Profile können
auf tiktok gemeldet werden doch selten
werden sie dann auch entfernt die
ExpertInnen raten sich ein
online-meldestellen wie RIAS in
Deutschland zu wenden die Antisemitismus
erfassen und dokumentieren denn von
solchen Inhalten geht eine Gefahr aus
eine unglaubliche Gefahr der
Normalisierung von Antisemitismus und
auch des überschwappens in ist reale
Leben das zu das aus antisemitischen
Worten oder Mims in den sozialen Medien
dann halt offline Taten werden
auch Aaron und seine Freunde stoßen auf
tiktok häufig auf Hass und
Desinformation
in letzter Zeit ist es eine Art Trend
das Leute die Kanye wirklich
bedauerliche Dinge über jüdische
Menschen sagen
und viele glauben diese schrecklichen
Verschwörungstheorien wie zum Beispiel
dass der Holocaust nicht real war
für sie ist tiktok aber viel mehr ein
Platz für Spaß und Information mit einer
Milliarde Usern kann man auf der
Plattform ein riesiges Publikum
erreichen
tiktok ist ein sehr einflussreicher Ort
und es ist schön dass Aaron und seine
Großmutter die Möglichkeit hatten ihre
Erfahrungen auf so eine bedeutende Weise
zu teilen
gehört zur letzten Generation der
Holocaust Überlebenden ihre Geschichte
trägt Aron auf Social Media weiter
die Geschichte wird nicht mit mir
sterben sie wird mit der nächsten
Generation weiterleben man muss erinnern
denn zuerst verbrennt man Ideen und dann
Menschen
ihre tiktoks sind eine Warnung an
künftige Generationen und ein
Vermächtnis gegen das Vergessen
da gibt es viele antisemitische
Äußerungen aber er beschützt mich davor
ich bekomme nichts davon mit denn das
wäre sehr schwer
[Musik]